everyone in this gym in manchester
seems to have one thing in common they
all dream of becoming professional
boxers
this club is more than just a place to
spa
it's our life it's our second home we're
here every day pretty much and
it's what we love doing and then like
like i say when it was took away from us
we
go to the gym it's no good no good for
us
they're finally back in practice after
months of being stuck
at home brogan cunningham works here
he just about got by on universal credit
when they were closed
it's hard because as you know as an
adult you've got to pay for things
you've got phone bills you've got to pay
for your car you've got to pay for all
sorts so
when you've not got that constant money
coming in it's hard
out of the inner city and in the student
area ella robinson is about to retake
her second year
long covered put her studies on pause
she's almost recovered physically
but she's worried about catching the
virus again
i used to have like panic attacks quite
badly um
and i don't want to get into the state
where things become like new triggers of
like going to university
if i'm worried about it then i'd
probably end up
getting panic attacks again ella's
having her second jab in a couple of
weeks
and she thinks vaccine take-up among
students here is high
one of the biggest incentives for them
going abroad gets
much easier george body just turned 18.
his family are going to tenerife but
he's only had one jab
so he'll have to quarantine after they
fly back and that's when
term starts if that and
everyone were to go on holiday without
me
it would be very very upsetting and for
everyone
because you know it's it's a
family you know to go on holiday and
have fun
and while i'm staying home in my bedroom
i'll test it it'd be very upset but i
could understand it i couldn't
understand it george is desperately
trying to get a second dose
but he thinks it's unlikely he'll be
able to take new holiday pictures
this summer becky cottrell sky news
manchester